and then the last two years we actually  got ubi and we realized it doesn't work  and here's why  so forty percent of america's uh money's  been printed the last two years whatever  the numbers you've seen it i've seen it  we've seen it all over the place okay so  where did the money flow we send this  1200 oh my god it's gonna change  people's lives what we realize is low  and middle income families the reason  why they're there sometimes because they  don't have the right financial habits  they don't know how to save they spend  they're you know putting back into the  market they're buying products and it  goes back to the business owners oh my  god amazon he got richer oh my god elon  musk he got so rich how did he become  300 billion oh my god all these  billionaires and all these well yeah  because ubi money always flows back to  the rich